yes Kristen where did you grow up are
you from originally originally I'm from
South Carolina
let's see Myrtle Beach I've been here
for six years now I actually came out
here to try to get clean up heroin but
that didn't because I was here when the
South Carolina - yeah a lot of thought
is not here I know right no it's pretty
bad there - yeah um my boyfriend sold
heroin that I was with oh yeah I went
from doing fells to doing the heroin
yeah and then when I came out here it
was so much cheaper that I really got
bad into it that's how I ended up in the
wheelchair oh really
somebody put battery acid in my dope and
gave me a hot shot yeah so it burnt me
from the inside out I got lost 60% of
the muscle in my left leg 40% in my
right leg and 10% in each arm from where
the acid burnt through my skin yeah a
year ago yeah I just learned how to walk
again I hope so I'm confident if the
doctor said if I keep practicing cuz
muscle has memory if you keep practicing
with it then there's a good chance I'll
be able to do it again so we're you stay
out yeah I have a tongue
[Music]
whatever I can you know girls do all
kinds of things for money these days not
always the best things but you know yeah
yeah definitely that it's kind of
dangerous out here but still gotta take
care of yourself and eat every day yeah
you know it's hard for guys your
situation is oh yeah for sure
it is women there's easy way out right
yeah cuz the men have that way harder
cuz they don't just have a [ __ ] they
can't just go make some quick money like
that being in wheelchairs it it's so it
hurts so bad I can't make money like I
used to do at all yeah nobody wants to
pick up a girl in a wheelchair you know
yeah so it's tough I do I have a
daughter she's 19 where she South
Carolina
my father did yeah so you were kind of a
fun street yeah I got divorced when I
was 23 from my husband and after that my
life just fell apart and I started doing
drugs and been doing a member sentence
just raising my daughter
I worked my dad owned a bar and I worked
for him and what you see down the road
for you for the next five years do
you have to get your place back right
yeah I'd love to learn to you know get
stronger and I'm going to the methadone
clinic now so hopefully I can keep
myself going in the right direction with
that and maybe one day get a job that
would be nice
and I'm working on getting housing so my
main goal is to just get off the streets
yes for sure it really does the to take
advantage of you because they see you is
like more vulnerable being a chair I
think sometimes they do plus I'm really
friendly and I like to talk to people so
they take advantage of people that they
see are nice they see that as weak you
know yeah sure and like a lot of the
tricks they'll try to like have sex with
you and then not pay you and kick you
out the car and then [ __ ] I'm seven or
eight blocks from home and I can't walk
what what do i do then you know I gotta
have somebody pick me up literally and
carry me back yeah that's happen so not
good
yeah not everybody is a good person out
here you know just wondering if they're
ready
yeah a lot of the times they're far and
few between that's for sure it seems
like everybody out here has an ulterior
motive you can't really call anybody
your friend because you don't the ones
you like close to you are usually the
ones that are the first people to hurt
you or rob you or the nicest kindest
person will do whatever oh for sure
there's no limits when it comes to the
meeting they're fixed you know I know
that myself
anything their kids yeah literally yeah
literally yeah
it's terribly you I heard with great
parents my parents were wonderful my
father was in the military for 27 years
my mother was a housewife I grew up like
on and off of Air Force bases good
schools I had my mom got sick with
cancer when I was 13 and she died when I
was 15 so that was pretty hard than it
was just me and my dad and he got this
new girlfriend and we didn't get along
and everything just kind of spiraled out
of control after that now me and my dad
don't talk anymore but he did raise my
daughter and I do still talk to her
thank God but yeah I I've tried to talk
to him since my accident and being in
the hospital but he still won't talk to
me so I guess he's still mad for some of
the stuff I did
ya know probably like with everything
yes thank you what are you using this
for nice very cool so just just like
information for people but for young
kids that might be considering getting
into a gang right oh good it just it's
just a good bit of information for them
to look at me right so they can stop
before they get it son especially the
games right you do that
damn for prison that's a guarantee and
that's it
can I tell you that goes without even
there's no chance of I see people get
shot and killed and beat up to here
every day so and I would hate to see a
teenage girl go through anything like I
went through so if this helps anybody in
any way that's great that's great your
son you're doing a good thing that's a
positive message to try to deter our
younger generation from growing up into
this you know yeah yeah and it can get
so serious it's life and death out here
every day so if you can stop them before
that I think that's a great thing
yeah no problem